estos soldados ucranianos se están
preparando para su próxima Ronda de
fuego de mortero están apuntando a las
fuerzas de Infantería rusas que avanzan
hacia bakmuth disparan cerca de 200
proyectiles al día
es un lugar difícil es un territorio
difícil de defender
hay que librar muchas batallas hay una
concentración muy grande de Infantería
enemiga están poniendo todos sus
recursos en ello
el grupo paramilitar ruso Wagner está en
la primera línea de la batalla por
badmud sus mercenarios intentan rodear a
las fuerzas ucranianas el jefe del grupo
emitió un mensaje de audio diciendo que
la lucha era cada vez más feroz
marcho
las fuerzas armadas ucranianas están
lanzando reservas adicionales e
intentando mantener la ciudad con todas
sus fuerzas decenas de miles de Soldados
del ejército ucraniano están poniendo
una furiosa resistencia el derramamiento
de sangre en la batalla crece día a día
soldados ucranianos aquí en el pueblo de
chatziar a 10 km de backmud están
ayudando a evacuar a los últimos civiles
que quedan allí el pueblo está en la
carretera hacia el oeste y cerca de la
línea del frente no tienen más remedio
que huir de los combates nos vamos
porque hay disparos este es nuestro
séptimo lugar de residencia los otros
fueron destruidos
impactaron en esa residencia
el camino de las fuerzas rusas hacia el
resto del donbas y en particular hacia
la Ciudad de clamatorosk a 50 kilómetros
al Noroeste